[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ابرد نجوم السماء خمسه النجم الثالث من
المربعانيه وشباط الاول وشباط ثاني
والعقرب الاولى السم والعقربه الثانيه قدم
عقربه بسهم ودعتنا الاسبوع المنصرم
وعقربات دم سلمت علينا هالاسبوع وعقرب
الدسم باقي عليها اسبوعين وتواصلنا
فالعقارب ثلاث الاوله برد بالليل والنهار
والثاني برد بالليل ومعتدله بالنهار
والثالث معتدله بالليل والنهار لسعه
الاوله قاتله لسعه الثانيه مدميه لسعه
الثالثه حاره مثل حراره الدسم لا طاح على
اليد من قربوا الكيه لا ينسى مواجعه ومن
راى السم لا يشقى كمن شرب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفي نهايه موسم العقارب يتساوى فيه طول
الليل مع النهار وتشرق الشمس من المشرق
تماما وتغرب من المغرب تماما ويبدا يطول
النهار على حساب الليل لمده ثلاثه شهور
تقريبا من طول الغيبات جاب المعاذير بهزما
ما عاد فيها غنايم لا تقول هالمره ترى
غيبتي غير ما عاد تفرق لو تبي تغيب
دايم
[موسيقى]